um
i think we need to revisit this hey
everyone i'm abby sharpe welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and we'll be taking a look at fitness
youtuber natasha ocean but first let me
tell you about my sponsor buildbar so
all my regular subbies know i talk about
building snacks and meals with my hunger
crushing combo in mind and that means
fiber healthy fats and protein so bill
bars are a staple for providing the
protein piece and bonus they actually
taste like chocolate because they're
made with real chocolate so today's
flavor is
talk about chocolate
coconut brownie chunk
what
oh yeah
she's a favorite around here
guys there are mounds of coconut in here
i lied mmm amounts of brownie
these ones are so good so good so good
[Music]
so
15 grams of protein super tasty on a sem
and paired with a source of fiber-rich
carbs like oatmeal or fruit and a little
healthy fat action maybe some nut butter
or nuts and we have a super super
saturating balanced snack so if you want
to give billbars a try check out my link
in the description and use my promo code
abbiesharp15 to get 15 off of your order
and you can pause the screen or look at
the description and check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating as
always feel free to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey and
if you are not already subscribed hit
that sub button ring that bell and
follow me over on tik tok and instagram
abby's kitchen so i first reviewed
natasha back in 2019 uh
yes
a year of hope and possibility but
anyways you can watch that video right
here if you'd like and i think over the
past two and a bit years we've both
grown a lot
personally i know that i've better
refined my position on things like
weight loss intuitive eating health at
every size body positivity and the anti
diet movement and i think my regular
followers all better understand the
purpose of these reviews it's not about
telling a creator their way of eating is
wrong or bad if it works for their body
and satisfies their needs my notes are
actually not even so much even for the
creator specifically themselves but
rather the purpose of what i in a day
videos in general should be
for meal and snack inspiration or recipe
ideas not as a coffee and paste meal
plan for all of you guys at home and as
a result my critique of said what i in a
days serve less as a nutrition
counseling session for the creator
specifically as it is more of a series
of teachable moments for helping all of
you
collect data on how to build satiating
and satisfying meals so i'm so glad that
we've been through this journey together
and my message now feels a lot more
clear though of course i am refining it
and learning and growing every day and
at the end of this video i'm going to
address my previous critique of
natasha's content related to intuitive
eating for fat loss or body composition
goals but let's first take a look at a
recent day of eats for natasha
[Music]
okay this toast looks awesome we've got
fiber-rich carbs in the bread apple and
granola plus protein fiber and healthy
fats in the chia and peanut butter i
also love making chia jam for the week
so i'm going to leave a link below to my
go-to recipe
this is my jam this is my turn that song
off this is my jam
but chia seeds specifically are a great
sprinkle as i call them for good
digestion because an anti-chia seeds
contains 11 grams of fiber which kind of
gels with water in the gut helping to
reduce cholesterol and blood sugar
levels improve regularity and increase
satiety so i see them as a hunger
crushing combo triple threat all on
their own so when we were in greece i
didn't really plan on doing any workouts
however there was
an insane looking gym so i snuck like
two
two little workouts in there just
because i felt like i had to honestly i
just i really did it would have been an
opportunity
missed so as i discussed in my video on
eating intuitively on vacation i think
it can be very hard for some of us type
a personalities to let go of our rigid
workout and eating routines when we go
on vacation but i think traveling is a
really great way to kind of throw
yourself into a more intuitive lifestyle
by forcing yourself to re-evaluate
routines that maybe aren't serving you
well and it sounds to me like even
though natasha put no pressure on
herself to work out while in greece that
as a fitness lover herself it was
actually just like a really fun thing
for her to do to try out the amazing
facilities and that's actually typically
what happens when we remove the pressure
and the rules from fitness and food they
actually just become something we like
i love weight training
it makes me feel really strong so in
case you're new to natasha's content in
early 2020 she suffered a lower back
injury which set her back on her
training for several months but she's
been slowly rehabilitating and regaining
her strength back and it's clear that
this progress really brings her joy
which obviously we love to see just tell
me the plates don't elevate
right
this looks like an amazing salad right
here so we've got loads of protein in
the salmon and the chickpeas healthy
fats in the fish and olive oil and lots
of fiber-rich veg and while there is a
solid amount of carbs in the chickpeas
so probably around 30 grams depending on
how much she had in her bowl for an
optimal post-workout snack after intense
workout like this we might get better
glycogen recovery with a bit more carbs
in there so that could mean adding in
some pita on the side or throwing in any
leftover cooked grains to her bowl
[Music]
oh my gosh i just want to watch that
caramel folding action on slow-mo all
day if you say fold in
one more time it says fold it in
everyone who knows me in real life knows
that salted caramel and caramel popcorn
and ice cream are my three favorite food
groups of all time so this recipe is
definitely my jam
okay now i know this took time so it's
not like this bowl of happiness is going
down right after the workout but hey i
mean if we want to replenish those
glycogen stores i talked about with
salted caramel i wouldn't be mad about
it and while i strongly get the sense
that natasha didn't deliberately have a
lower carb lunch to accommodate her ice
cream snack i also think that it likely
feels intuitive to you know crave a
creamy bowl of ice cream after having a
fresh protein and produce rich meal
salad for lunch so i approve
this is gorgeous uh super beautifully
balanced and also nutrient rich so we've
got carbs in the rice fiber in the slaw
protein in the chicken and some fat in
the dressing and cooking oils now a lot
of people ask me if white rice is bad
for you and to that of course i give a
big fat hell no no food is bad for you
as you guys all know by now and white
rice actually has a lot of redeeming
qualities so it's an easily digestible
carb packed with b vitamins and it's
also lower in impurities like arsenic
and its healthified cousin brown rice so
if you prefer white rice to brown like
we do in my house don't feel the need to
forgo what you like because wellness
culture says so my tip is to do as
natasha did and pair that white rice
with hunger crushing compounds which
will help to drive down the overall
glycemic load which will help to
stabilize insulin and blood sugar levels
and keep you saturated longer
okay that pink apple too pretty and
since i get the sense that there are no
food rules for natasha that there's no
necessary need to have a more decadent
dessert if she isn't feeling it
sometimes you're just craving something
juicy and sweet and light and a bowl of
fresh fruit just hits different but i
will say if you struggle with hunger
during the evening or throughout the
night we could give this snack the
hunger crushing combo treatment by
combining the apple with some cottage
cheese and some nuts or dipping it in
some full fat greek yogurt or almond
butter so what are my overall thoughts
on natasha's diet well based on our
calculations on this particular day
natasha is consuming somewhere in the
range of
2200 calories and even though these are
very rough guidelines this likely falls
within her needs especially given that
she's training less frequently and
intensely because of her injury so her
body might naturally crave less calories
than it did during her more intense
training days pre-injury and seeing as
natasha identifies as an intuitive eater
and it seems quite apparent that there
aren't any hard and fast food rules at
play i trust that she has a very good
handle on her own personal data so yeah
i feel that she would respond to her
hunger without judgment as she did when
she felt like she needed an extra
chicken leg for example at the end of
her dinner meal she's hungry she eats
she craves ice cream she has ice cream
now with that said i did want to share
some thoughts on natasha's approach and
her own personal goal to lose fat or
change her body composition while
simultaneously describing herself as an
intuitive eater so in the past i have
felt the need to
react to folks who like co-opt the
intuitive eating movement as another
trendy way to change your body because
the first step in the og intuitive
eating model as developed by elise resh
and evelyn tripoli is to reject the diet
mentality and surely after that it is to
honor and respect your body as it is in
practice when someone is healing their
relationship with food we really need to
see these steps mastered first before
you can learn any gentle nutrition tips
and i think that's where messages that
combined intuitive eating and body
recomp can get quite messy for folks to
grasp i think it can be unfair to tell
someone that they can lose fat and build
muscle through intuitive eating when
that was never the intention of this
eating model that doesn't mean that you
won't lose fat or gain muscle when
eating intuitively but i would say
intention is really really important
here by definition most intuitive eating
therapists and coaches would agree that
purposeful manipulation of the body is
not compatible with the intuitive eating
model for all the reasons that i just
outlined a moment ago and that i discuss
in my intuitive eating series right here
but before you guys rip into me for
calling out our girl natasha on this i
want to just say that i don't get the
sense that she's trying to sell you some
false promise of like an intuitive
eating fat loss diet i think ultimately
this comes down to semantics and that
what she's describing is really just
eating mindfully and listening to her
hunger cues and satiety cues and
incorporating gentle nutrition tips that
she knows are favorable to her aesthetic
goals without sacrificing her happiness
and i want to make it clear that above
all else i respect body autonomy i see
nothing wrong with having aesthetic
goals or sport goals and as long as the
behaviors required to help you meet
those goals aren't triggering for you i
say go little rock star but ultimately i
think when i reviewed natasha two and a
half years ago i was still at a point
professionally where i really want to
follow the rules i didn't know there
were any rules and it's kind of taboo in
anti-diet circles to talk about fat loss
or weight loss especially in the same
breath as intuitive eating but i'm like
an old mom now i've been through two
years of covid and isolation hell and
five years of ivf and and pregnancy and
motherhood and breastfeeding so let's
just say i'm getting too old to give up
about words i don't want to be a
gatekeeper of this term i didn't create
it i didn't write the book and i
realized that today in 2022 it's taken
on a meaning somewhat different than
what was originally intended by its
creators and a lot of ie experts are
going to completely disagree with me on
this but i think as long as we are not
deceptively selling intuitive eating as
a weight loss or a fat loss diet which i
don't think that natasha is then i
personally don't really care what words
are being used call yourself an
intuitive eater a mindful eater a circle
eater i don't care
if you want to label your diet you do
you i think you guys should absolutely
do
your own thing i think it definitely
would piss other intuitive eating
experts off out there but i'm just at a
place and a point in my career where i
really want to just meet people where
they are and i have a lot of newfound
patience and empathy for people's own
learning and eating journeys what i want
to say about natasha's journey
specifically is that whether or not a
goal to lose fat is against the tenets
of intuitive eating i do think she's
clearly in tune with her own cues and
isn't going to restrict herself
unnecessarily despite her goals so
she'll have an extra piece of chicken if
she's hungry or she'll leave half her
toast when she's full there's nothing
extreme about anything going on here
that i would personally deem like a red
flag or problematic i also think because
of her solid relationship with food that
she's better able to integrate gentle
nutrition tips into her day without it
triggering a restriction binge cycle so
let's take a quick look for some
examples
i kept ordering delivery
but
i made healthier food choices in my
delivery deliveries so i'd be swapping
that creamy mash from nando's with some
corn or some broccoli or some sweet
potato so i think this is a great
compromise to balance like a convenience
meal with more nutrient-dense side
dishes i don't honestly think she needs
to forego the creamy mash if she loves
it so much but maybe adding a veggie
side in there can help to naturally
shift portions and offer more variety in
her day without triggering scarcity
mentality i'll be eating about three to
four portions of veg and two to three
portions of fruit never put any foods
off limit so if there's a celebration or
if i just really fancy it i can eat any
food that i want so i've discussed a
similar gentle nutrition tip in my video
on weight loss here but i do appreciate
that she's not being super rigid or
strict or taking on a grossly calorie
restricted diet instead she's simply
focusing on what she can add to her diet
like more fruits and vegetables which
will not only add more nutrition but
will also naturally edge out some of the
more calorically dense foods without
eliciting that cycle of restriction or
guilt she's not swearing off all of her
favorite foods like donuts but rather
she's making easy swaps when it feels
doable for her and giving herself the
grace to lean on convenience foods when
needs be so in conclusion while any
intentional fat loss regimen isn't
officially compatible with the intuitive
eating model i think a lot of what
natasha describes is kind of like gentle
nutrition tips combined with honoring
her hunger and fullness cues and
honestly if that works for her amazing
you do you but i do think most people
watching our videos are not quite there
yet they're not so able to
simultaneously learn to trust their body
while actively seeking weight loss so
it's important to not try to duplicate
natasha's experience or anyone else's
for that matter so i say for
science-backed inspiration and realistic
balanced meals and snacks check out
natasha's impressive repertoire of
content but as always speak to a
healthcare provider about your unique
needs before attempting anything she
does for herself same for me same for
any other influencer out there and on
that note that is all that i have for
you guys today if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on who you'd like to see
me review next subscribe to the channel
and i'll see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]